looking back at our code here's how we
would expect that to play out we might
build a me and Ben such that they
delegated to card out methods rather
than copying all of the car methods
properties onto a me and Ben here when
they're stored in the observing
even though the ami object doesn't have
its own dot move property will delegate
that look up to the car dot methods
object which does have a move property
let's see how that looks in practice the
problem here is we're using an object
literal these two curly braces in order
to build the brand new object that's
going to be an instance of car and
whenever you use an object literal to
create an object you don't get to define
what the prototype of that new object is
going to be so we're gonna have to
switch it up and use our other technique
for creating objects which is object
create that technique does allow us to
set the prototype of the new object now
whatever we put in here in between these
parens is going to be the thing that our
new object delegates to so what object
do you expect we're going to need to
pass to object create in order to set up
the right delegation relationship for
every new instance of car no we aren't
done refactoring the rest of the code
yet but before I move on I do want to
get this line right